god of thunder king khan you have finally
joined our fight well they say better late
than not at all this is very nice as you
know we used to live in a peaceful of us
but then our gods were murdered murdered and now
our sacred temple has been left unguarded and hope
was dissolved to control of its power it is our
most sacred shrine and it desecrates not for long
king you can't tell them what happened here
today tell the time that thor the drag tag
motley crew misfit desperados the tide in
the battle and that's their names in history
the odds may be against us but i'll tell you
this for free here we go this and here and now
so that's the ex-girlfriend is it the old
ex-girlfriend judy foster jane foster the
one that got away the one that got away
that means escaped yeah yeah must be hard
for you to see your ex-girlfriend and your
ex hammer hanging out and getting on so well
what you up to bro
come to daddy
hey, there you are. hey i was just calling you
to the shadow realm how do you know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like no other
this is if color feels to trend it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we
need let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbow is that catchphrase or
something she's only gonna throw for a minute
i mean saving lives she's quite good at it but the
rest of it she needs work how many
catchphrases have there been a lot
hang on he moves through shadows and he's going
to the shadow realm it seems like that's where
he's going to be the most powerful you're
right we can't just go marching in there
it could be a trap are you thinking what
i think you're thinking i'm thinking it
and giant goats. oh, look at those! They are wonderful
yes, they are. they also scream quite a lot.
human handshake to the asgardian shake
into the snake that you cannot trust
really dragging this out let's
finish the classic asgardian high one
Welcome back everyone this will be my new thor
love and thunder trailer video there's a whole
bunch of scenes that they release so we'll break
it all down a whole bunch of easter eggs here thor
trying to rival spiderman and ned leeds for like
the longest handshake in the mcu if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're also doing an imax ticket
giveaway for the movie because it's getting ready
to come out all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber and just post your favorite easter
eggs so far on the video all my post credit scene
videos easter eggs for the full movie will start
posting after it comes out i will do a review for
the movie too but just starting at the beginning
the first big clip is the guardians of the galaxy
getting a distress call which we see in the later
trailer footage like thor loses all the weight in
that funny montage then they get a distress call
taking them to this centaurian looking planet
that's the race that yondu comes from it's kind of
hard to tell what this character's name is but it
sounds like a y sound there weren't subtitles
on the video that i was watching but it's all
part of that scene where thor is just being lazy
meditating under the tree wearing that poncho just
trying to pretend like he's super enlightened when
really that's not the case like he's just trying
to figure out what he's supposed to do with all of
his god to your power now going forward like what
do i do in the universe if i'm so powerful in the
guardians have to come yell at him to come help
out during this big battle that's happening and
they're saying that the distress call is because
but sounds like gorr has come and killed their
gods leaving their temple unguarded when he talks
about the power being left unguarded and being
threatened like they're trying to save them so
that someone doesn't steal their power that's also
from the gorr comics too i think that's a bit of a
sly wink of gorr taking the power of all the gods
that he kills giving him his power-ups so that he
can kill more powerful gods just making it easier
for him to go around the universe killing all the
different pantheons the second scene takes place
at new asgard after he's come back after they've
had that scene where he recognizes jane foster he
recognizes mjolnir and he's come to the town hall
to try and rally the revengers 2.0 so they can
go and try and find out what's going on with gorr
and they have that longer funny scene of korg
making fun of jane foster calling her jodi foster
and him trying to call mule near to himself in it
not working for some reason like all of a sudden
stormbreaker just shows up like oh hey yeah i
was totally calling you and not my old hammer
korg also makes the joke about jane foster being
the one that escaped thor like ah the one that got
away that means escaped they did say they'd have
flashbacks to explain why they broke up in the
past they referenced it during thor ragnarok like
they'd already broken up when ragnarok started
the whole reason why mjolnir probably doesn't come
to him might have something to do with the jane
foster mighty thor arc because during that he had
become the unworthy thor and just literally could
not lift it because the enchantment kept him
from doing it but the reason for that happening
was completely different that was nick fury
whispering in his ear gorr was right because
this was happening after the gorr storyline and
the movie is just combining both of those story
lines so they're happening at the same time i
think him being unable to call the hammer to
himself has something to do with gorr's storyline
during the movie like he's not unworthy in the way
that you thought him before like he thought that
he was unworthy but because gorr is going around
killing all the gods of the mcu because he feels
like they're unworthy they're lazy they don't care
about their subjects i think that thor being kind
of lazy and not knowing what he's supposed to do
with his life the guardians of the galaxy getting
tired of his presence like time to get out of here
buddy that'll play into the whole idea that he
can't call a mule near to himself so i think the
idea is at least during part of the movie or this
first part of the movie he won't be able to just
use it during any of these battles and if it
wasn't clear stormbreaker does not have the
same worthiness enchantment on it which is why
anybody who's powerful enough could wield it
like thanos for instance is able to put his hand
on stormbreaker and try to use it against thor
the rest of that scene though actually
has a big reveal about some of the plot
thor explains that gorr has been using the shadow
realm which explains where the necrosword comes
from in the mcu it comes from this alternate
dimension and when he says it's a place where
color literally fears to tread it explains
where all these scenes are happening later
in the trailer where you see this energy arcing
around the planet with the necrosword where you
see them fighting each other where the only color
is coming off of the god tier weapons like zeus's
lightning bolt in off of thor himself because
he's literally god giving off god to your energy
the shadow realm is a place from the comics
but it's like a huge deep cut it actually
predates the creation of the thor character
like they retconned it into marvel later on
it comes from the strange tales comic book in
the 1960s which is where doctor strange comes
from but stan lee and jack kirby created doctor
strange after the shadow realm in the way they
explained it is it just an alternate dimension
of pure shadows ruled over by a warlord and when
they retconned it in they said that that warlord
took over hulk's shadow and tried to use that
as a backdoor to take over the main mcu dimension
so basically all of gorr's minions behind thor
here in this place are meant to be creatures from
this alternate shadow dimension like shadow demons
and like i said that also probably explains where
the necrosword comes from like the sword is made
up of energy from this alternate dimension jane
foster's joke catch phrase about bringing the
color is about the rainbow bridge itself which we
actually see unfurl later in the trailer remember
stormbreaker is capable of opening bifrost
wormholes and that's basically what the rainbow
bridge is is like a wormhole through different
parts of space and then they decide to go to
omnipotent city to get more information about the
shadow dimension and about gorr which is where all
the zoo scenes take place them confirming it
and probably the scenes of the cosmic entities
later in the trailer we see both thor and gorr
in that same place where all the statues of the
cosmic entities are i've already done a much
longer video about which cosmic entities are
in this room here so i'll link that below but
like yes there's the living tribunal there's the
watcher there's infinity there's eternity there's
death there's entropy a lot of like the really big
classic cosmic entity characters that you saw
during the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline
and during a lot of other related storylines we
just saw the living tribunal as they were passing
through the multiverse and doctor strange too so
now is like the time where you start explaining
who some of those huge characters are they're so
op they're way more powerful than the celestials
and the other really cool thing about this new
trailer is that they actually have celestials at
the godhead meeting here at omnipotent city
like as they take off in the goat boat with
the rainbow bridge you see two celestials kind
of back out of the way so they can get through
the thing about the celestials is that they aren't
gods the godhead is a meeting of all the gods but
it sounds like they're kind of combining a lot
of those ideas during the movie like all the most
powerful cosmic entities and most powerful gods
are meeting to decide what's going on with goro
the god butcher the fact that he shows up in this
underground hall here too with the cosmic entities
makes it sound like he shows up at this omnipotent
city and just winds up cleaning house killing most
of the gods in here and then after that they go
down to this place here to get more information
the other funny joke that you may have spotted in
here is a big reference to jean-claude van damme
yes he does the splits to try and keep those
two bikes apart and jean-claude van damme is
known for doing the splits in a lot of his movies
but it's actually a reference to this commercial
that he did which itself was a parody of himself
doing the splits and movies if you remember a long
time ago it was him doing the splits between
these two 18 wheelers it was like the most
epic crazy commercial you've ever seen so r.i.p to
thor's nuts who knew he could do the splits like
this but the whole idea of him doing the splits
in jeans is a very jean-claude van damme thing
like that's how limber jean-claude van damme
is and then they have the funny joke about his
longest handshake ever like this is how we do it
in asgard just trying to prolong the moment as
long as possible the joke about the snake that you
cannot trust i also think is a loki reference to
because he has the whole back tattoo r.i.p
loki it will be kind of disappointing if we
don't see some kind of cameo scene or some small
reference to the version of loki from the tva and
the loki series now he's a variant so like he
didn't experience ragnarok or any of infinity
war with him he just saw it happen in that tape
but like he does remember growing up with the
version of thor just that his timeline diverged
during the events of the original avengers movie
there's a little bit more guardians of the galaxy
footage in this too like we hear groot say i am
groot and it is vin diesel's voice like he still
does the voice even for younger groot they just
pitch shift it so that he sounds younger after the
fact if he spotted any other easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments my full review
will be up after they release the embargo that
should be the week before the movie comes out and
i'll name a giveaway winner in my next big marvel
video everyone click here to learn more about all
those cosmic entities in that last big thor
trailer and click here for my full ms marvel
episode 3 video with a whole bunch of connections
and easter eggs for the shang chi movie in the 10
rings thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!